I want to introduce well I want to go
through spark and do some examples of
how to analyze spark on data that would
not fit into our in our memory so show
you how you can use our too you know and
spark together to analyze some data that
wouldn't wouldn't fit in there and I'm
confident that you know and not just
confident I'm excited and optimistic
about the direction some of these
technologies are going again just from a
personal standpoint to be able to see
like some of the tools that are now
being delivered to analysts on
large-scale data is extremely exciting
and so I I hope we can you know some of
that you know that you can see some of
that here in today's discussion alright
so if you've been analyzing data with
our chances are you know you're probably
familiar with doing some analytics on
the laptop maybe you you've used on the
server as well you might be connecting
to you've got to be connecting to some
sort of data store whether that be a
data warehouse or a database or a feed
or flat files or a file share or
something and you're probably you know I
shouldn't say we probably we all have
extracted data into our for an analysis
in our and that works great for things
that might be a few gigabytes or even
tens of gigabytes but the but there's
also and that's fine because a lot of
problems don't require any more
firepower than that and for that that's
a set of problems are will take care of
the solution by and large through you
know the large number of packages that
are available to us
however some problems are you know very
large have hundreds of gigabytes or
terabytes or even petabytes truly large
data they're involved with you know you
know production workflows there might
involve like some streaming technologies
they might have like a variety of you
know different you know complex data
sources and pipelines that need to be
addressed at different stages and for
those problems
question becomes you know what is the
role with our there right like if you
have if I have data that has that are
truly large and I want to do analytics
on that data then you know how can I go
about doing that now there are a number
of ways to address that problem spark is
not the only one but I want to show you
why you know spark is you know is it is
one way that you can solve that problem
so what is Apache spark it's a fast in
general engine for large-scale data
processing right so this is and I want
to emphasize the engine part of that
right so this is used to manipulate data
at scale this can integrate with the
Hadoop ecosystem which is important
because you know often the data that you
want to access is already in Hadoop so
then that the fact that spark can
integrate with that ecosystem is
extremely important
it also supports spark sequel which is
basically hive QL or hql it has nice
built in machine learning algorithms
that we're going to talk about that
increase the the toolkit for analyzing
data at scale and it's designed for
performance this was designed to work
interactively with the analyst as
opposed to batch processing and finally
it's extensible so you can extend this
platform this spark platform to include
other modules or custom code or other
things that you want to contribute to
that ecosystem so sparkly are sparkly
are is a an R package that our studio
built so we you know we built it and
released it on to cran a few weeks ago
it's open source it's free to use anyone
can use it and also mention you know
SPARC and Hadoop are also open source so
you have a complete open source stack
here if you choose to use that we
integrated spark spark they are with our
studio ide
we created a new spark pain on that
allows you to browse the data and the
metadata inside of your spark instance
and we
created a deep liar back in with sparkly
are as well so that you can access you
can use deep liar to do all of your
sequel translation on your spark data
frames finally we made it extensible so
you can plug other things into it like
we previously discussed so if you're you
if you're investing in spark if your
organization is investing in spark
there's really nothing stopping you from
using it with the full power of our and
that's my main message to you today that
if your organization is interested in
spark or using spark then the are
analysts can access it as well and
that's important because spark appeals
to a wide audience so other people that
use spark might have skills in Scala or
Java or Python and we want you to know
that if you're if your tool of choices
are you can also use spark to do your
work now spark sparklie are communicates
with apache spark through a through
api's and i want to talk about you know
three of these today the first ones
sparks sequel which we used applier for
and then the next ones machine learning
and then the third ones the extensions
so let's jump into the first one which
is deep liar now if you haven't seen
deep liar deep deep liar is basically a
fast and consistent tool for working
with data frame like objects both in
memory and out of memory here's an
example of deep liar code you can see
that you have an object here called my
table and you're going to filter it and
you're going to select some columns and
your this example uses the pipe notation
so that all of these commands get
chained together into one execution at
runtime so I wanted to put a quick plug
in for deep liar because I've used our
for a long time and for most of my
history I wasn't using deep liar because
it didn't exist
and I would try to make my our code look
really pretty and I would always fail
miserably with that that attempt and
when I started using deep liar then my
code started looking a lot more
regulated and a lot cleaner and that
meant that when I went back to my code
six months or nine months later I could
actually read my code again this was a
huge benefit because if you're familiar
with you know nesting commands and you
know these other you know data
manipulation techniques in are you can
know that you can write very powerful
efficient things that are completely not
understandable six months down the road
so that's my plug for deep liar
it does it will clean up your code and
regulate your code there's some nice
efficiencies with deep liar as well
meaning deep liar will actually speed up
a lot of the commands that you do inside
of our that's what I meant by that all
right the other thing I want to show you
is our notebooks so our notebooks is an
R markdown document and if you've seen
our markdown not documents you know
that's our Web authoring tool for you
know doing documents in our the
notebooks give you interactive code
chunks and inline inputs and we're going
to be using those today so I just want
to give you a heads up that that's in
there because notebooks hasn't been
officially released it will be released
in the next few weeks so I just want to
give you a heads up that will be will be
using that today great so now that we've
done the intros and the background on
spark I want to get to the real meat of
the presentation which is actually using
sparkly R and spark and D plier so here
what we're going to do is we're going to
manipulate some data with the plier and
spark using that spark sequel API and
we're going to do that on a local
instance of spark so this is not going
in this in this case this will just be
on my local server so let me jump over
to that and
talk to you a little bit about our
studio server so this is the our studio
server version of our product you can
see that because I'm in a web browser
and this is the professional version of
the product and you know that it's
professional because I have multiple
versions of our here and I also have
multiple sessions that I can support
here as well alright so what I want to
show to you today is this new spark tab
that's been added to the IDE if I do a
new connection I can say I'm going to
connect to local so this is just going
to be local to my machine no I'm not
getting not connecting to a Hadoop
cluster here I'm just keeping it right
on my my local machine I'm going to go
ahead and use deep liar I'm going to
choose spark 162 which is the default
and Hadoop - 6 2.6 so these are
dependencies that are required to run
spark it writes this code for me which
is nice and then I'm going to go ahead
and copy it into a new or notebook
look at that and I'll hit connect ok so
this is the notebook it's got this green
bar it means that this these commands
are running and you can see that it's
going to go ahead and connect here to
the spark context on my machine if you
haven't created a spark context a
connection before you have to install
spark and there's a simple command for
doing that as well it's a spark under
store install it will actually install
the spark dependencies that are required
for you to run on your local machine ok
so it looks like it connected here which
is great and I can choose the spark UI
and I can see that the jobs ran so this
is all this is not done by our studio
but done by spark you can see things
like storage there's nothing in storage
and you can see the executor it's just
the driver node which is me now if I
want to put data into it I can just go
ahead and do like I have a variety of
ways to do data but here what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do spark read
park' and I'm going to do the connection
and I'm going to say
I'm going to create a new dataset called
Titanic and it's going to load in from a
data source called Titanic
now parquet data is data that is a data
format that is colander based and it's
compressed so it works very well with
spark it's a very efficient way to like
load data into and out of spark so park'
well you know is often associated with
spark so I'll go ahead and run that and
this just takes a second and you can see
that this these data now ran into spark
and it's also in spark UI I can hit the
down arrow I can see the data that's in
spark and I can click this tab and again
I can see all of the data in spark so
this is great because this is not data
that it are in are I'm looking at data
that are in spark and that's very
powerful because that means that when
you connect to your spark context that
are sitting on top of Hadoop you will be
able to browse all of those tables in
the hive meta store with your spark tab
and I'll show you that here in a minute
when we go to the cluster mode that
functionality is extremely extremely
useful I found as I played around with
this so let me so that's how to connect
now I want to show you manipulating the
data with spark sequel so I'm going to
open up a new file here and this one's
going to be the flight status or what I
want to do is I want to take the data
from New York City flights and I want to
put that into my my spark instance as
well so you can see I'm going to put in
the flights data and the Airlines data
and they're gonna show up right here and
again I can take a look at this this is
what the flights data look like you get
a record for every flight tells you what
the carrier is like United Airlines
where the origin of the airport is and
the destination of the airport and how
long that flight took plus it tells you
if it was running you know on time or if
it was delayed so here had a departure
delay of two minutes great so now that
we're all set up let's go ahead and run
some activities here so
the first one I want to show you is deep
liar or deep liar verbs which are going
to be things like select filter arrange
mutate and summarize here you can see
I've written that into a single query
where I've done the Select filter
arrange mutate I just run this it's
going to go ahead and do all those
operations on spark and return it for me
in the console because I'm using the
notebooks
so here I've run sparks equal on top of
a spark data set that's in the spark
context and returned the results very
very quickly this is for a small data
set but this would scale up to very
large data sets as well and we'll do a
large data set here at the end of the at
the end of our demo if you want to do
grouping you can group by things and
then summarize here so I can in this
case I can find out the mean and
standard deviation of the delays for
every month so month one here I get all
that window functions if you use window
functions in sequel you'll this know
that this is here because this is going
to support anything that's in high of QL
and D player supports window functions
so I have ranked the top three departure
delays from worst to least worst by
carrier so you can see this is a two
hundred twenty five minute delay those
poor poor people
okay joins you know you don't really
have sequel without joins oh so what I
did here was I one version of spark on
one context and I didn't restart
I should have restarted let me restart
this and we'll use a version 2.0 so 1.6
was kind of the standard a few months
ago and 2.0 was released was released
recently and so some of my scripts are
1.6 and some of them are 2.0 so let's
load this back up and we'll go back to
the joins so the joins that our support
of course our inner joins outer joins
right
left joins the typical joins and in my
example I'd do a single join but you can
do nested joins as well so let's come
back here and run this
so this basically joined Airlines and
now I can actually see a label for
American Airlines actually has a label
Virginia Virgin America has a label as
well
sequel translation all of these things
here are available to you in sequel
translation so all of these functions
here what I'm going to show you is I'm
going to show you a case statement I'm
going to show you another windows
function and then I'll do the join and
this time instead of actually running
the query I'm going to render the query
for you so you can see what is being
passed back into spark so here's the
here's the query deep layer translates
things into your window function your
case statement and also your join so
it's joining using carrier so this is
the sequel statement that is being
passed back and this is also very
powerful because that means that deep
liar can be used with other databases
and if you haven't tried that I would
encourage you to look at the deep liar
syntax or the deep liar help pages to
learn more about how deep liar can
communicate with your sequel databases
alright laziness and piping so here what
I've done is I've created two queries
and the second query is based on the
first one so this one I do some basic
processing and on the second one I say
oh yeah I forgot I want to I want to
convert air time in two hours so I'm
gonna divide by 60 and I'm gonna take a
look at that operation so the first one
when I've run the first one nothing runs
went around the second one nothing runs
but when I run this one then it executes
and then finally we start saying like
once all of this all this data has been
manipulated so hopefully you've seen now
that you can manipulate all of your data
you'll very easily with deep wire once
you're ready to move that somewhere or
use that
you know make that reusable you can
register the table and cash the table
and assign a reference and what that
will do is that will populate that
reference up here so now I have access
to this table and since I cashed it it's
in memory and since I've created this
reference I can refer to it at any
future time and typically what you're
going but your you'll probably want to
do is you want to collect that data into
R so the collect statement is what
brings the data from SPARC and into R
and then you can look at it in R so this
collect statement becomes extremely
important because what you're going to
what you probably want to do is do your
heavy lifting in SPARC and then when
you're ready to do some visualization or
additional analytics or publishing
you'll probably want to bring over a
very small representation that data into
R and collect is what lets you do that
so here I brought JFK to SFO into memory
these are all the flights that went from
JFK to SFO and it shows and it's ordered
by the amount of time it took to fly so
from greatest to least and you can page
through all of these which is great
alright so once that data is in R it
doesn't stop you from doing anything
else like you cannot you know visualize
it here or you can look at you know
pairwise comparisons which is not a
function that's in SPARC but as an R and
you can tab between these two by hitting
these thumbnails there were two commands
here and then there's the two thumbnails
that go with each command all right and
finally there's some other niceties like
you can sample the data which is great
because you might want to sample some of
your data from spark into R and it's as
easy as specifying the number of the
size of the sample that you want and
then you might want to write out the
data into Park a format for future use
so that's basically it in a nutshell
the last thing I want to show you about
this notebook is that once this has all
been
and you've commented your code code like
this you can hit preview and you can see
all your code with all the comments and
it's all formatted in HTML so this
document now
it describes exactly what we did we can
see the queries that we ran we can see
the the images that were the we can see
the HTML table here is embedded in the
code we can see the images also embedded
in the code and this is a single file
object that I can email out or I can
publish on our pubs or I can push to our
new product called our studio connect so
this is meant to be shared and built
upon for reproducibility purposes okay
that in a nutshell is sparkly R&D plier
let's move on to some of the other
topics here like I mentioned before d
plier is is one of the interfaces with
spark another one it's ml and extensions
so spark ml lib is Apaches sparks cable
machine learning library it's very easy
to use and it's easy to deploy and it's
a hundred times faster than MapReduce
extensions extensions make sparkley are
really easy to invoke spark applications
we have a website here called spark our
studio comm that has all sorts of great
information and one of the things that
it shows here is ml and the extensions
the ml algorithms that would be
available to you are these algorithms
and you'll recognize I mean I think I
think it recognizes most of these right
because there's analogs to these and are
but these algorithms are going to run
inside of spark you also have
transformers utilities and extensions
and then when you're ready to do
something like this let me show you a
quick example here again using a spark
161 and using the empty cars I'm going
to partition the data into
training tests in seed that I'm gonna
run a linear regression using the
standard our formula but I'm not going
to run it in R I'm going to run it in
spark and then I'm going to summarize
that fit from the spark model and you'll
see that it's formatted very similarly
to what the linear model command looks
like in R then I can take a prediction
function I can predict the test data on
it collect it back into memory and then
into our memory and then do a plot so
here finally it's the analysis of that
data the plot again is an R but the
analysis was done entirely in spark so
if you're interested in using other
functions you can have access to them
through the extensions and this page
will explain to you how to do them
basically it's going to it's often going
to boil down to this invoke command
which opens up this spark shell which
gives you a lot of flexibility on how to
do that
one of the main extensions I want to
talk to you about today is h2o s
extension for sparkling water
they created an h2o extension which you
can access here under the ml tab that
allows users to quickly go between the
spark data frames and the spark the
sparkling water data frames and that's
important because you get access to a
whole new set of algorithms so here now
you have access to all of these GL n
algorithms and I'm sorry that I can't
actually run through all these today we
just don't have enough time to do all of
this I would love to do that maybe we
can do that in a future session we're do
a deep dive into algorithms and in h2o
but just know that you have all of these
x2 in your tool kit now as well I'm
gonna highlight just a few of these here
one is PCA you notice that there's some
really nice formatted output here which
you know makes an analyst life a lot
nicer
they also have you know some plots that
are being done you know for you in in
your work which is very can be very
handy and then they have some really
powerful things here like you know a
grid search so I'm going to go ahead and
set up all these parameters here and
then I'm going to run all of the models
and compare the models automatically
using this grid search so you can see
that I ran 36 models here
none of them failed and I ordered the
models from best to worst and the best
model had an MSc of 88 and it was model
35 and these were the parameters so I've
used h2o to find out exactly which
parameters are going to give me the best
performance h2o will you know does a lot
of great things for you the big two in
my opinion is increases the performance
of your you know analytics and it
extends that toolbox for doing analytics
so if you want to learn more I encourage
you to go ahead and take a look at our
documentation on ml extensions and h2o
alright so moving on SPARC deployment
like I said before you're probably not
going to get much use out of SPARC on
your local machine it's nice to play
around with and learn from but if you
can do it on your local machine you
probably can do it in our anyway for the
most part so you know SPARC the reason
that you really want to use SPARC is
when you've got distributed data in a
cluster mode and there's a variety of
ways to configure your environment and
your infrastructure to you know use
SPARC
I'm just going to call out these two
here that are around like a standalone
mode and then also if you're using a
Hadoop with yarn there's a yarn client
connection as well that will allow you
to you know use that mode we do
recommend at this point that you use our
studio server along and that you put it
on the driver node or what's sometimes
called a gateway node that is basically
part of the spark cluster and the Riesz
and why is because the driver is going
to be doing a lot of connections you see
these two arrows here become really
important these drivers are going to be
communicating with the worker nodes and
so there's a lot of interactivity that's
going on within the cluster itself so at
this point we recommend putting our Co
server with the connection UI and and
are on that spark master and using a you
know connections doing something like
this to connect to your tier spark
cluster and that's the exact
configuration I'm going to show you
right now I'm going to show you a spark
sparkly R with 1 billion records it's
200 gigabytes of data uncompressed it is
the infamous New York City Taxi trips
data but it's all going to be loaded in
spark there's no way you could load that
data and operate it efficiently in open
source are I will say that there are
other ways to analyze this data doesn't
have to be sparked so just be real clear
that it's not doesn't have to be spark
but if you've chosen to use spark and
and that's the technology that you want
to use then this demonstration will
hopefully help you get started on your
larger projects alright so this is this
these data now live on an ec2 instance
I've got a I'll just pull up the spark
UI here you can see my executors here
are I've got five of them and I'm going
to analyze the taxi trips data and I'm
going to load up all of these packages
that are going to help me do that
and I want to point out that I'm going
to tune the cluster nodes somewhat I'm
going to decide how many cores I'm using
and you know on the driver and on the
executor and then how much memory for
each and then I'm going to use a yarn
client version 2.0 point one spark and I
already ran this because it takes a few
minutes to cache all of the data but the
ultimate output here of this
set up is going to be the trips in
parque format which are joined and I can
see all of my data here so this is what
I was saying before all of these data
live in your hive meta store and these
are all these are very large tables so
this table is a billion records and I'm
only showing the top 1,000 but I can
browse that easily from inside the IDE
right now and I can see the geolocation
as long as well as the borough and the
NTA which is nice because a lot of my
analyses are going to be picking up
doing trips between geographic locations
so I can see this table and I can see
all the you know I can see this view of
it and I can see all the other tables in
my hive meta store on this five node
they do cluster so the first thing I
want to do is I just want to get a sense
of like how big this date these data are
so I'm going to do a count and I'm gonna
see what the counts look like by year so
I'm going to group by ear and and run
this and keep in mind again this is you
know a billion records and it's designed
to be fast so we'll see how fast it is
go ahead and run it it pulled off the
size the data very quickly and then it
pulled off it did the counts by year
very quickly and I can see again here
and here my outputs so I just ran a very
simple aggregated query on 200 gigabytes
of data and it took you know I don't
know what that was a second or so now I
collected the data and ran things ran a
plot command so I don't I don't know if
you've run any like MapReduce jobs but
you'll notice that was much faster than
MapReduce all right this section of the
the data is going to show you some nice
you know window functions again it's
doing percentiles which is pretty cool
it's doing some UNIX timestamp
conversions on the date so it's
translating the dates
it's going to map the difference between
two locations and then it's going to
plot them and so you can see again the
running this statement and collecting
here is what we're pausing on and then
and then we're good to go so again this
you know function very quickly now
granted you do have a where statement
here right that's going to limit the
data but it's still going through all
that data to I haven't indexed it on
these locations not like a traditional
database so I'd argue it's still running
fairly quickly now now that I did that
and this is just briefly this is your
pickup time and this is your trip
duration and in time so you can see that
at 15 which is 3:00 in the afternoon
trips taxi trips end up taking a lot
longer between these two locations than
they do in the middle of the night and
then also in the morning basically the
commute times right okay so this one is
going to actually run a model I'll go
ahead and kick it off here there we go
you're gonna we're going to partition
the data entertain a training and
testing I'm gonna cash that data so that
I can run this model here's the formula
again you can use your standard are
formulas and then I'm going to run ml
regression on the the training data and
I'm going to summarize it and then I get
I can see the most important uh who has
the largest T value fair amount right
fair amount has the most significance in
this case which is which makes sense
because we're predicting trip amount if
you want to do some
with HTML widgets you can do the same
thing similar similar type of code here
I'm going to do some aggregations an
HTML widget is basically a JavaScript
library that is included in our that
make you know these plots interactive
here I can see the pickup is the airport
that's the green circle and then the
drop-offs are the popular most popular
drop-offs so that there's another
LaGuardia Airport here JFK and LaGuardia
and then um you know Midtown
purrs to be the most popular drop offs I
do not live in New York City but that
makes sense to me
all right so so that's h2 that's some
HTML widgets and then finally I'm going
to show a shiny gadget here and shiny
gadgets or you know shiny apps that you
run inside of the IDE and I can choose a
pickup location and a drop-off location
I can do a plot the first one of this
takes slightly longer than subsequent
versions of this so here's the pick-up
and drop-off between those two locations
here's the map so that's the pickup and
the drop-off and here's the data now if
I want to change this I just go back to
the inputs right and I just can choose
anything else I can do
West Village and then go here and this
will update in a second or two there you
go
so you can do any sort of interactive
analyses that you want here to the map
again and get a sense for you know how
performant this is on a large-scale data
set that's residing in a Hadoop cluster
and then finally when you're done with
this again you can hit the preview
and you've got the entire document here
that is reproducible ready to share
great documentation for any future use
that you might do again this this is
going to be embedded in here as well as
well as all the other images and the
code and the pros they use to describe
your data okay so that's analysis on you
know a billion records you know I I want
to put one more plug in for the the the
sparked our studio comm website that
documents a lot of these things there's
some great examples in here that you can
use to get started including that taxi
data as well as some of these other nice
notebooks and an end to end analysis
here you can run you know dashboards and
shiny applications on this as well and
you can see how we've got about that in
this example and you can get a lot more
information around young deployment and
and and the various function calls as
well this is a complete documentation of
the package alright so it looks like
what type of ec2 instance was used when
running the New York City Taxi data that
was I used the c3 instance and I think I
was using extra larges that helps c3 is
the computer optimized are there plans
to support tidy are using spark so I'm
not sure exactly what functionality
you're you're looking for with tied ER I
mean that the the tidy verse is
obviously extremely important to us
you know the deep-fryer package is
generating the sequel code that is being
passed back to spark so I think I think
that's as much as I can provide to you
at this point I was
about I was asking about deep learning
functions I was asking about deep
learning functions available in spark
that must be a follow up from something
else
so for deep learning functions that's
obviously going to be an h2o related
question so you'll want to dig into h2o
there is an h2o package and I kind of
glossed over that fact in our that might
be a good place to start if that can't
answer your question then go back to
sparkling water hi when exporting data
into spark does do the attributes are
the attributes kept yeah I mean that's
so when you try my Explorer you're
talking about collecting the data so I
think the question is like if I've got
yeah
data and spark and I collect it back
into our our you know do the formats
stay the same for the most part yes
they'll be the same like numerix get
copied over to numeric and and and
whatnot I find this webinar very
interesting my question is about
simulations using this package assures
me that I can get simulation results
faster I mean I think that's one thing
that that h2o example is supposed to
show you on the grid search so if there
are technologies that allow you to do
that then yes but let's keep in mind
that some of the things that are
happening here are in our and then other
things are happening in in spark so you
really need that simulation those
simulation techniques to exist in spark
in order to leverage them with sparkly
are sparkly are itself doesn't doesn't
do any of those things if you want to
create your own of course you can create
your own and then make an extension and
that would work as well okay i main man
main difference between sparkly or and
spark are yeah so sparkly are is you
know our is a you know adds that deep
layer back-end it communicates with
those api is its downloadable from from
cran and has those extensions with it
spark are is a completely separate
architecture and was done by a
completely separate group
so those are two independent and
distinct technologies here I find the
let's see my question is about
simulation if I we already answered that
can you do Monte Carlo simulation using
spark
I think Aria answered that that would
have to be done you know in by one of
the ml or h2o algorithms or another
extension I I believe there's a lot of
neural network functions in there so my
guess is that those are probably using
some MCMC but you'll have to do some
more homework on figuring out exactly
which ones make that you want to use is
the beta version of our student use
sparkly R or will the current version
work without the SPARC tab and the new
features yeah you don't have to use the
IDE to run sparkly are you can run it
you know you can production lies it in a
spark in a are shell or whatever just
run it from the terminal it'll it'll
work fine
it looks like the beta and sparkly R has
trouble with your month date amassing do
you think the functionality will be
available I so that sounds like you've
already used it and you already have
some experience I encourage you to
commit those are to send those issues to
the github repo sparkly art is open
source so we would love to hear from you
on that so that's a great way to great
place to end if you have feedback for us
please send it to the the github repo
and I'm sparkly are and we look forward
to hearing back from you